[Music]
before I underwent this makeover I
personally consulted with tanning and
braiding professionals I wanted to do
this right we even brought a camera crew
to record my research okay I'm at sunset
10 this is in Studio City and Kaitlyn
yeah you own this this property is I
cried you I'm one of the business owners
very good first of all
rate my skin tone well you look fair we
can go like lighter on your face darker
on your legs it just depends on what
you're looking for do people do
different shades for different but
literally absolutely for instance girls
will go lighter on their face for makeup
purposes
there's a woman ever make maybe one
breast darker than the other is that
unheard of no but they like their
breasts a little bit darker so they look
bigger wait doctor breasts look bigger
is that true there's a certain technique
you can spray their chest so it looks a
little bit more like her keys so perky
bigger yeah you said spraying can make
things look larger
why you happen nothing
what's this quick 10 yeah you can spray
it you get sprayed me if you want even
try it
what's better just bad what's the matter
I know it you look like a roast chicken
right now I'm delicious by the way
finish your work on other things now got
a tan
what's in here oh um those are my files
say you don't know okay oh you know what
we did we brought with us a guy that
works on the show Kramer
this is Caitlin okay nice to meet ya
Caitlin Kramer Kramer Caitlin do you
mind if we test this level to Tanner on
you I don't have a choice so no no you
really don't
you you'll I'll fire you but seriously
if you don't want to do it and you don't
have to do it anything but you will lose
your job you don't have to do it god I'm
just crystal clear okay where's a good
area to spray you
[Music]
remember you don't have to do this
now this is going to slowly can I use
the instant ones you can use innocent
ones as well okay I just want to speed
up the process I just want to try and
get it going
see this is what I was talking about
more you know what I mean yeah
is this bad he's just normal melting no
it just looks like someone threw ham
gravy at you that's what it looks like
to me
I'm Conan what is your name boo so boo
so yes I bet people tell you all kinds
of things when you're doing their hair
do they talk about their lives they tell
you things yes yes yes do you give them
advice on their life yes so you're like
my therapist right now I could tell you
things mm-hmm sometimes I'm very
attracted to my guests on the show but
you know I'm a good husband I love my
wife mm-hmm I love my kids
mm-hmm but occasionally you know
someone's on Martha Stewart this is
painful at times that's just there's no
way around that
right I mean you're very good obviously
but is it painful
a little bit I feel sometimes like my
the skin on my scalp is being torn from
my skull but I might be sensitive you
know they say redheads are very
sensitive to pain I'm gonna start crying
and I don't want you to take it
personally
I know you're doing it very gently it is
not your fault
but I haven't felt pain like this in
quite a while but I'm fine
quick question who complains more about
the pain me or say a three-year-old girl
[Applause]